and we're well into all the fields
February but let's be honest sometimes
the feeling we feel is just annoyed yeah
that happens it's real yep and as you
know Sebastian can't stand people they
bother him so even his loved ones so
it's time to play something we're
calling I love you but please stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Jesse I love you oh we've loaded a bunch
of things that bother us about those we
love into our random generator when I
say go the generator will start flipping
when one of us says I love you but
please stop the generator will stop on a
topic and the person who said stop will
get 15 seconds to vent their heart I
don't do that I'm gonna be way longer
heart out on the topic that we've been
dealt with sorry already
yes okay don't feel Sebastian you're
first get the generator started here we
go I love you but please stop that's
real okay when she takes listen my
wife's when we go out to eat takes
forever to order she doesn't use her
menu time appropriately so I'm like
alright but I think the waiter will come
I'm like I don't have baby she's like
all right you go first I'm like all
right I'll have steak with mixed
vegetables back to you did you think I
was going to take go first not skydiving
is this Clinton free or what does this
one have rice in it or does this when
I'm like just eat at home food for you
here anyway that's funny so a lot of
your necks you okay all right let's get
the generator going again I love you but
please stop okay wow he's like aggro
when the tea is half full okay so my
boyfriend blesses her I feel like this
is gonna be like I don't want to throw
him under the bus it's okay row row him
so he's very lovely and he but he gives
me tea and he brings me tea but he
always brings me tea that's like if this
is the cup this is how much water's in
it I'm not want you to spill or he says
it's because he doesn't want to spill as
he brings it to me but I'm like it's
fine it's just tea
I want the full thing
because I'm not trying to just get a
taste yeah I'm trying to get like the
full experience that's just rude I want
the hydration and it's like wow it's
rape it's true
I don't think just then don't bring it
right yeah yeah I'll get my own team
I'll get my exam it's the little thing
it's the little things yeah okay it
would be weird that would be weird
okay my turn I'm not close to the button
here we go move it spin it
I'm ready I'll get up please up when
that oh this is a real thing don't laugh
at me it's a real thing I am so annoyed
because I like toilet paper and this is
my house and talk about my house I like
it coming over the top people come to my
house and they reverse it like it's
their bathroom like I'm like I don't do
I do that at their house to their maybe
I didn't come to my house and flip my
toilet paper around I get there and I'm
ready and I'm like ah I know it's a
weird thing I hate the toilet paper do
you like it over and I like a loose roll
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this